[Musique]
dans la banlieue de strasbourg ce matin
le carnaval a déjà commencé pour un
couple de retraités aller ginette 60 ans
et gérard 62 ans s'apprête à faire un
bond de 5 siècles en arrière
dans quelques jours ils partent en
italie pour participer aux plus célèbres
carnavals du monde et ils ont la passion
du détail costumes accessoires cette
année pour leur cinquième participation
ils ont tout misé sur l'époque de la
renaissance afin de briller dans la cité
des doges
deux détenus de rois de france tout
agrémenté d'une touche très personnelle
toute l'année on recherche dans les
magasins suivants les chaussures des
chaussures de femmes taille 44 ça va
très bien porter ces toilettes raffinés
c'est un peu une deuxième vie pour le
retraité jamais il n'aurait imaginé se
travestir ainsi quand ils étaient cadres
ingénieurs j'étais quand même directeur
j'avais beaucoup de responsabilités dans
la société et donc bon j'avais peur un
petit peu de ce que les employés ne
pouvaient unir et c'est donc là j'ai une
coiffure qui nous permet de passer à la
version historique sans perruque le dada
de ginette ancienne coiffeuse c'est de
concevoir les perruques et les dizaines
d'accessoires
un travail d'orfèvre pour lequel elle
s'inspire des livres d'histoire
ça se ressemble la petite cape le
chapeau la collerette
ginette a pourtant privé son seigneur
d'un attribut historique
par contre on n'a pas fait à l'époque
les hommes marquer leur virilité au
travers d'une première danse sur la
voilà qui était très voyantes
on le voit sur les photos oui c'est moi
je réponds que c'est sa patrie on n'a
pas fait si on avait voulu être purement
historique de l'intérieur pas de signe
de virilité mais des dizaines de masques
perruques chaussures ou encore chapeau
chez ginette et gérard on se croirait
dans un musée ça c'est un vie lukas quoi
on évoque le gaz
celui d'arras pour monsieur réplique
voilà ma chaudière bois c'est la robe de
6,6 effacer la robe de 6,6 me allez
fourchette est ce fed
c'est un tout va bien et cela pour
sauver or les voleurs voilà on est
également en fait on n'a peut-être pas
assez joué étant jeune je n'ai pas eu
trop le temps de porter des jolies robes
de princesse alors maintenant je pense
déjà les princesses mais pour eux il
n'est pas seulement question de s'amuser
je suis parti pour faire ses valises ses
valises dont une une de chaussures peut
être c'est toute leur collection qu'ils
emportent avec eux car cette année il
compte faire leurs premiers pas dans les
soirées de prestige de venise mais se
faire accepter parmi l'élite du carnaval
va se révéler pour eux un véritable défi
la vente commence car ils vont devoir se
mesurer à des concurrents venus du monde
entier et à l'imagination sans limite
le carnaval de venise est l'un des
événements populaires les plus célèbres
et les plus anciens au monde
apparu au moyen-âge cette fête hors du
commun transforme la ville pendant dix
jours en seine de la commedia dell'arte
synonyme de raffinement et d'élégance
le carnaval attire chaque année des
touristes du monde entier
et le plus étonnant c'est que 80% des
costumes et son français
parmi eux caroline et thierry des
festivaliers de la première heure en
passe pas inaperçu il s'est passé pas le
but
il sent les costumes et le d'abord pas
de carnaval
avec eux nous revivrons l'ambiance
artistique et précieuse des salons du
xviiième siècle à venise beaucoup de
talent nous suivrons également dany
nathalie et leurs groupes de collégiens
qui prépare ce grand rendez vous depuis
deux ans leur objectif remporter le
fameux concours de costumes qui se
tiendra sur la mythique place saint-marc
[Musique]
vous a laissé filer que nous allons
décider
[Musique]
en compagnie de ginette et gérard nous
découvrirons les balles d'époque
costumés nous pousserons aussi les
portes de somptueux palais où se
déroulent des soirées privées incroyable
glamour et sulfureuse
plongez dans les coulisses du carnaval
de venise
[Musique]
à saint prex petit village suisse au
bord du lac léman des participants
inattendu s'apprête à partir pour venise
dans ce collège
certains élèves ont droit à un cours
plutôt particulier ce matin deux
répétitions du menu est une danse à
trois temps très en vogue au xiiie
siècle dans quelques jours ses neuf
adolescents participeront au concours du
plus beau costume du carnaval de venise
c'est le pari fou que s'est lancé dany
leur professeur qui s'improvisent
aujourd'hui chef de balai vous êtes des
gens importants roi de la fête
donc je veux parler les trois
répétitions de danse mais aussi
confection de leurs propres costumes
pour ces adolescents en décrochage
scolaire cela fait partie d'un projet
pédagogique
ils y consacrent tout leur mercredi
après-midi et leurs week-ends depuis
deux ans à l'image de tony 13 ans le
plus jeune de la bande mais à tout se
passait très chaud voilà là quoi elle
s'est brûlé
mais pour tony comme pour tous ses
camarades reste quelques détails à
régler notamment sur les techniques de
maquillage
[Musique]
ils ont une semaine pour maîtriser le
pinceau avant de s'envoler pour venise
puis d'aller là bas on va rigoler à
l'origine de cette folle aventure
deux professeurs dont dany la maître
d'oeuvre du projet pour que le rêve
devienne réalité
les enseignantes ont eu l'idée de vendre
des calendriers et des cartes postales
personnalisées
au total elles ont récolté dix mille
euros de quoi financer leur voyage et la
confection des tenues
là encore du cousu main par les élèves
eux-mêmes c'est maintenant l'heure du
dernier essayage pas simple pour tout le
monde notamment pour anaëlle 16 ans dans
les moments vraiment la pression en fait
d'être en princesse dedans la jeune
fille plutôt introverti compte sur cette
expérience unique afin de s'affirmer un
peu plus de la confiance en soi c'est ce
que les enseignantes aimerait apporter à
leurs élèves en participant au carnaval
fait un petit pincement au coeur parce
que je me dis que c'est ils sont les
vedettes et faire briller et pour
espérer briller dans ce concours
international
tout a été calé au millimètre près né
vers moi avec vos sceptre d'entraîneur
comme on va droit à la tête droite
droite oui vous êtes des seigneurs moi
je voulais dire que battre à tout les
deux vous avez vu qu'on est très très
ému je pense que nous ça restera de
projets scolaires le plus incroyable est
fait pour qu'on peut être le vôtre aussi
en tout cas je suis super fier de vous
moi aussi
verdict dans quelques jours les ados
défileront sur la place saint-marc
devant des milliers de personnes
un grand moment d'émotion en perspective
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard la célèbre
place saint-marc s'apprête à accueillir
près de 70 mille touristes pour
l'ouverture du carnaval est parmi les
premiers arrivés dans la capitale
vénitienne sa impeccable gérard à
ginette après un périple de 750 km ils
parviennent enfin à la cité des doges
avec comme chaque année toujours la même
émotion
il ya les vaporetto le grand canal
tout y est
détenu à villa s'est excité le trajet en
vaporetto pour accéder au centre
historique de la ville
c'est un peu leur madeleine de proust
c'est sur ce bateau qu'ils sont tombés
amoureux de venise lors d'un premier
séjour il ya huit ans les canaux les
gondoles les centaines d'églises et les
palais majestueux tout ce qui fait le
charme de la ville des romantiques les
émerveille comme au premier jour
on ne se lasse pas de regarder tout ça
valait le long du grand canal
on arrive à venise c'est pas là palacio
cas d'euros s'est amusé on peut le
visiter c'est joli comme tout pour
rejoindre leur hôtel
pas question d'emprunter les chemins
touristiques la dernière mais plutôt les
chemins de traverse
car gérard et ginette sont ici comme
chez eux ça les petits passages des
petits passages secrets
à chaque fois qu'il vient à venise le
couple pose ses valises dans le quartier
sao paulo un choix stratégique situé en
plein coeur de la ville c'est l'endroit
idéal pour se rendre au carnaval
meziane meriane ils sont gentils quand
même qu'elle a un peu renaissance ici
gérard et ginette ne loue pas une simple
chambre d'hôtel mais un appartement
spacieux à 160 euros la nuit on a une
très élevé paradis au total ils vont
débourser près de 2000 euros pour 10
jours pour la vue mais surtout pour un
grand espace de 60 mètres carrés qui va
vite prendre des allures de loge de
théâtre car ils ont apporté plus de
quatorze costumes chacun et gérard a
tout prévu pour le système d donc j'ai
léger de la colle et de la ficelle j'ai
détourné miss ce pistolet à colle chaude
j'ai des pinceaux il suffit d'avoir un
petit problème sur un costume
quand on est à 750 kilomètres de chez
soi on est bien embêté provisoirement
très utile aussi pour régler un petit
problème bien particulier à la cité des
doges
le problème c'est qu'à venise y'a rien
qui ait droit et le parquet ici il est
pas droit alors ça descend tout seul a
venise les maisons sont construites sur
pilotis au gré des marées les fondations
bouge légèrement l'ex-ingénieur a dû
trouver la parade ce n est pas qu il
bouge de trouve
voilà je vais voir j'ai peut-être être
obligé de le caler encore là il descend
tout seul il est maintenant l'heure de
choisir leur costume pour leur premier
grand rendez-vous du carnaval
ils ont été sélectionnés pour défiler
lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
et ils tiennent d'emblée à en mettre
plein la vue des mouchoirs
parce que le lendemain matin c'est le
jour j sur la place saint-marc noyé dans
la brume
le couple de retraité strasbourgeois
s'est levé aux aurores pour être aux
premières loges
louis 15 pour gérard et comtesse du
barry pour ginette ils font déjà la
traction pour faire patienter les
touristes
l avion et bellissimo délai de six mois
des baies les civils on n'en peut plus
c'est encore et on en sourit lui sourit
on y prend en photo mais la vraie star
du jour se prépare en coulisses au pied
du campanile
cette jeune italienne de 19 ans
s'équipent pour le vol de l'ange
ça va là tu es à l'aise ça m'irrite un
peu là ça me fait mal bien accrocher les
jambes le dos
comment ça va irène je commence à être
un petit peu tendu là dans quelques
minutes elle sera suspendue à 80 mètres
du sol oui c'est un rituel alors depuis
le haut du campanile je vais faire un
vol jusqu'à l'estrade qui est à l'autre
bout de la place saint marc en fait
c'est très impressionnant
cet envol spectaculaire à midi pile
c'est le rituel qui donne le coup
d'envoi du carnaval
à du gruyère idéalement placé gérard et
ginette retiennent leur souffle
ça y est c'est parti
malgré le harnais de sécurité ce vol de
l'ange c'est toujours une opération
risquée
c'est comme si la jeune femme s'est
lancé d'un immeuble de 30 étages
[Musique]
certains parlent à notre atterrissage en
douceur
assurément c'est un exploit dont la
jeune italienne se souviendra toute sa
vie je vais bien je vais bien
à un moment quand j'étais tout en haut
j'ai été vraiment impressionnée mais ça
s'est très bien passé
et puis il y avait beaucoup de monde
pour me voir je suis très contente
là on est rentré c'est parti pour dix
jours de fêtes de bal masqué et de
défilés
[Musique]
super dit
cette année le couple participe au grand
défilé d'ouverture pour la première fois
les années précédentes
il était de l'autre côté de la barrière
avec les touristes
l'armé un petit peu on prend des retards
coco lapin
ginette et gérard ne sont pas au bout de
leurs émotions
dans quelques jours ils vont vivre une
autre grande première
ils sont invités à une fête somptueuse
dans un palais de la ville en compagnie
d'une poignée de privilégiés car à
venise il ya le carnaval accessible aux
touristes et certains rassemblements
très privé réservé à quelques initiés un
milieu très fermé dont nous avons pu
percer le secret
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée
c'est dans un café sélect de la place
saint-marc qu'a lieu l'un des rendez
vous les plus prisées du carnaval à
l'extérieur on se presse pour observer
un bien étrange spectacle des
carnavaliers grimé comme au temps de
louis xiv
[Musique]
impressionnant sac et hors du temps
c'est plus délicate
c'est réseau de tout regard le problème
c'est qu'on regarde aussi la pression
des des prostituées en belgique
quand on est tous les gens sont derrière
les vitres et nous prennent en photo
voilà on y est c'est nous qui sommes
vraiment je pense juste au niveau des
costumes ce sont les personnes qui sont
amies en 2016 qui sont pas dans le coup
quoi là on est chez nous on est chez
nous en échange dans la maison et la
reine des lieux ici c'est caroline avec
ses amis cette costumière française
appartient à la caste des poudres et des
intégristes farouchement opposée au port
du masque vénitien
chaque année ils viennent du monde
entier pour un moment à part
caroline est devenu leur muse
connue pour ses tenues excentriques
elle fête aujourd'hui ses 30 ans le
carnaval et au fil du temps cette
courtisane des temps modernes a bâti une
petite élite qui ne se contente pas de
faire revivre les costumes d'époque
en effet caroline et sa bande ressuscite
pour quelques jours tout un art de vivre
inspiré du xviiie siècle pour le
découvrir
nous la retrouvons le lendemain avec un
ami comédien français lui aussi
nous l'accompagnons pour un goûter au
chocolat un peu particulier le rendez
vous du jour a été fixé dans un petit
palais renaissance au bord de la lagune
ici chaque après midi on se retrouve
entre poudre et comme à la cour du roi
pour l'occasion chacun a enfilé sa plus
belle tenue
[Musique]
présentation faite
il est temps pour la reine seigneur
émanant de passer aux choses sérieuses
je colle adhémar nous vous remercions de
votre présence nous vous souhaitons à
tous la bienvenue
nous sommes ravis de vous accueillir
dans ce beau palais où vous invitons à
exprimé de grandes toutes ces personnes
est bien votre passion c'est en toute
simplicité
[Musique]
chacun est invité à exprimer son talent
pour recréer l'ambiance de la monarchie
et dames messieurs les gestes un peu
curieux il est maintenant l'heure pour
la noble assemblée de prendre un petit
cours de maintien et de gestuelle madame
oui oui un peu plus oui parfait parfait
ces dames sont toujours plus élégante
que ces messieurs c'est curieux alors à
votre avis qu'est ce que ça peut être si
je fais c'est dans la colère mais c'est
un sentiment encore supérieur à la
colère la haine bravo madame c'est la
fonte alors le mépris c'est juste le
doigt crochet est ce qu'on pourrait
faire d'autres de rigolos à voile à
l'adoration
ça va être ce geste là beaucoup de
talent on a beaucoup de talent a cette
chance
mesdames et messieurs je vais danser
pour vous si vous voulez que je donne le
meilleur de mon âge je voudrais que vous
me laissez le maximum de places s'il
vous plaît laissez un petit peu pour le
final c'est le bouffon du roi qui va
tenter d'épater la galerie n'a pas pu
l'en la chaîne hi fi n'est pas vraiment
d'époque
la chorégraphie non plus
mais qu'à cela ne tienne la distraction
semble au goût des invités
[Musique]
caroline et ses amis se retrouveront
demain entre eux pour d'autres
festivités d'autrefois tout aussi
délicate alors qu'à l'autre bout de la
ville à la gare centrale où cia
c'est une entrée en fanfare pour nos
jeunes adolescents suisses et leurs
professeurs
[Applaudissements]
après six heures de train ils vont enfin
découvrir la ville dont il rêve depuis
presque deux ans
ils sont venus de leur petit village
suisse pour participer au concours du
plus beau costume est à l'image du petit
tony qu'ils sont plus que motivés comme
en la maintenant l'air de venise ne fait
pas mal ou pas à pas plus nos tentes au
cias et vous plaît ça trop stylé l'âge
comme sur internet les photos et tout ça
[Musique]
pour ses enfants en décrochage scolaire
ce périple loin de leur ville natale
dans un pays étranger est une première
peu d'entre eux maîtrisent l'italien
la prof qui va devoir gérer sa bande
d'ados pendant cinq jours a donc pris
quelques précautions montrer ça aux gens
vous dites merde ça reste quand même des
jeunes des jeunes enfants les jeunes ça
donne entre l'ado qui est encore
totalement mou et l'enfant qui roule
dans l'excitation c'est vraiment un
passage pour certains d'entre eux là il
va falloir
à venise le prix des chambres doubles
pendant le carnaval pour loger tout son
petit monde à moindre frais dany a dû
réserver un peu à l'écart du centre
ville
voici les quatre appartements ou élèves
et accompagnants ont posé leurs valises
budget 2009 100 euros pour 4 nuits un
peu moins de 200 euros par personne pour
le séjour nayala son beau fils à ce prix
là il a fallu se resserrer un peu les
deux magnifiques licence ce qui fait à m
ils n'ont que quelques jours pour
s'imprégner de l'ambiance avant le grand
concours du plus beau costume
alors pas de temps à perdre c'est parti
pour un petit repérage de la concurrence
et une visite de la cité des doges
ambiance colonie de vacances pour
explorer ce labyrinthe de ruelles
étroites
rien de tel que de se déplacer en
gondole mais avec un petit budget
le prix de la promenade s'annonce salée
bonjour combien ça coûte pour faire un
tour s'il vous plaît c'est 80 euros pour
combien de temps pour une demi heure
mais mine de rien oui madame
ah bon et pour 50 minutes pas plus
longtemps c'est plus cher pour un petit
tour d'une demi heure c'est gros c'est
45 minutes
cinquante minutes ce sont 20 euros 80
euros la demi-heure x 3 gondole les
adolescents ont eu le droit de manquer
une semaine de cours pour participer au
carnaval
mais malgré le folklore local
pas question de jouer les simples
touristes cette balade c'est aussi
l'occasion d'un cours d'histoire
grandeur nature au fil de l'eau alors à
garder cette maison là c'est un grand
palais et appartenu à une grande famille
le palais après c'est napoléon bonaparte
iac journée et elle cherche clooney
s'est marié à l'intérieur 14 ici c'est
le palau dalle fallait enfin la maison
et la famille de marco polo pour l'airé
nitia c'est très important parce qu'en
fait marco polo a ramené les spaghettis
lâcher et du coup c'est un symbole
important buzz aussi espère marquer
l'histoire de la capitelle vénitienne et
cette immersion dans les entrailles de
la ville commence à leur donner l'espoir
s'amenuise en faisant quoi en faisant
quoi demain en gagnant
après une heure de promenade il est
temps de découvrir la place saint marc
là où va se dérouler la compétition dans
deux jours ils vont défiler sur ce
gigantesque podium
un pont vénitien reconstitué en bois
destinés à un décor grandiose très
impressionnant pour cette bande
d'enfants dans deux jours la place sera
noire de monde pour espérer remporter le
premier prix les adolescents devront
affronter un jury pointilleux et des
concurrents venus du monde entier
notamment beaucoup de français
[Musique]
pour découvrir ses concurrents il y à un
endroit incontournable à venise un
endroit bien connu de ginette et gérard
mois la glace pour s'y rendre cet après
midi ils ont revêtu leurs plus beaux
masques et leurs plus belles tenues
renaissance la touche finale c'est le
chapeau fleuri original mais pas très
pratique pour passer les portes en fin
d'année
direction l'arsenal l'un des plus
anciens quartiers de la ville pour le
rendez-vous des habitués du carnaval
chaque année plusieurs centaines de
masques et s'y retrouvent en marge des
festivités officielles
c'est un peu la deuxième famille de
ginette et gérard après cinq
participations
tout le monde les connaît et les
reconnaît même malgré leurs masques
alors c'est nos amis rient gégé se
servent à présent via steam il ya une
allure et puissante à gentils ils
passeront sous le masque l'histoire du
code fleurs et le luthier
je pouvais pas ne pas les reconnaître
chose étonnante comme nos strasbourgeois
la plupart de ces colombinois requins
ont fait le déplacement depuis la france
en effet près de 80% des participants
arrivent de l'hexagone qu'est ce que
vous représentez la galette si le
carnaval c'est un peu la nouvelle
passion de nos retraités qui trouve le
moyen de pimenter leurs vacances en
italie
or des grandes périodes touristiques
[Musique]
le bien de tout apprendre comme le
monsieur qui vient du pays basque
paris 12ème séance en représenter à
l'adverse il ya toulouse que je serai
mieux encore il ya des mots parce qu'on
adore ça puis on se retrouve
ça commençait petit puis je pense qu'à
firth est passée a continué son travail
pour la plupart la récompense c'est
d'être mitraillé par les photographes ou
de remporter le prix du plus beau
costume
certains participeront au concours
demain contre les adolescents suisses
ginette et gérard eux ont une autre
ambition cette année briller dans l'une
des plus belles soirées du carnaval où
ils ont réussi à se faire inviter le
carnaval c'est en effet une occasion
inespérée de découvrir les secrets de
venise la cité des doges est un
concentré unique d'histoire avec ces
petits bijoux d'architecturé notamment
des palais somptueux qui appartiennent à
l'aristocratie dennis yens
c'est derrière la façade de celui ci que
se prépare la réception tant attendu par
le couple strasbourgeois
[Musique]
ce trésor du xviie siècle de 500 m²
s'appelle le palladio gradenigo il
appartient à flavia ils doivent ainsi
que son amant quoi hosted web rossi
signer demain soir elle reçoit 60
invités triés sur le volet alors elle
veut que tout soit impeccable
la riche héritière d'origine suisse a
racheté ce palais il ya quinze ans avec
son mari luc à internet et donc infinite
lémanique
ce membre de l'aristocratie italienne
qui cultive son allure grand siècle est
un architecte renommé également
passionné par la haute couture c'est mon
costume c'est celui que je porterai ce
soir c'est un dessin que j'ai fait nous
réalisons tous nos costumes nous mêmes à
la maison mon mari a des talents de
tailleur de costumiers et nous nous
réjouissons beaucoup parce que c'est
aussi la robe que je porterai ce soir
c'est mon anniversaire
flavia organise une soirée pour ses 50
ans mais pas seulement
la restauration de son palais et
l'entretien lui coûte très cher c'est
pour les finances et qu'elle a eu l'idée
de concocter des fêtes payante pour la
clientèle haut de gamme présente chaque
année à l'occasion du carnaval
sans cette manne impossible de sauver le
patrimoine vénitien aujourd'hui en péril
des palais sont vides
leurs habitants ont quitté la lagune
beaucoup de palais sont fermés depuis
des dizaines d'années car c'est très
difficile de restaurer ces structures
anciennes
c'est donc un peu pour sauver venise des
eaux qu'elle organise un souper raffiné
demain soir
comment fonctionne la gare c'est top 14
la tradition sera respectée jusque dans
l'assiette mais nice sous la forme d'un
grand buffet style xviiie siècle
[Musique]
tous les plats sont présentés ensemble
sur la table ovale et les invités va en
fait picoter on va interrompre en fait
sur menu par le concert et après il y
aura trois plats de la tradition
vénitienne qui sont présentés à la table
près de cinquante convives ont payé 170
euros chacun pour participer à cette
soirée d'exception dont gérard et
ginette qui découvriront pour la
première fois le faste des dîners
vénitien
ce matin c'est l'effervescence
pour la bande d'adolescents suisses et
leurs professeurs
obama
six ans
debout depuis 6h ils soignent leur
préparation pour espérer remporter le
concours du plus beau costume du
carnaval ils ont beau se préparer depuis
deux ans à une heure du défilé rien
n'est prêt dany ne sait plus où donner
de la tête pour effectuer les dernières
retouches et faire face aux imprévus ça
normalement ça se passe et pas la plus
haute couture mais c'est dans l'urgence
alors hier soir j'ai fait lourd l'aide
de nouvelles jusqu'à 1h30 du matin là je
pense pas qu avoir le temps pour le
faire avec du fil alors on triche un
petit peu vous verrez que la colle
c 'est toujours c'est leur suisse
fenêtre alors dont camarades nous
attendent donc il faut pas les faire
attendre
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que le groupe
d'écoliers va se retrouver sur scène et
devant des milliers de personnes pour un
concours international
alors forcément en coulisses à quelques
minutes de l'épreuve
le stress est maximum
[Musique]
les folles années
ciao
hasard du tirage au sort ce sont eux qui
ouvrent le bal de ce premier tour pour
espérer se qualifier pour les étapes
suivantes jusqu'à la finale ils doivent
finir premiers de l'épreuve du jour
c'est à dire battre une dizaine de
concurrents
c'est l'option pendant les heures à
l'école pendant une heure ils vont voir
leurs concurrents défiler sous leurs
yeux
la reine des neiges au bras de casanova
le baron macarons ou bien encore le
prince des ténèbres
au total une dizaine de participants qui
rivalisent d'inventivité pour convaincre
le jury
c'est enfin l'heure du verdict l'équipe
suisse a hérité de la couleur rouge
si les juges lève une majorité de
pancarte rouge ils sont qualifiés
si ce sont des pancartes verte
ils sont éliminés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais l'important c'est de participer
éliminée dès le premier tour
la déception est immense pour les ados
et leurs professeurs aucun n'est
d'humeur a tombé le masque pour montrer
ses larmes
[Musique]
je tiens à dire que je suis fier de vous
vous méritez ne prouvait la vie on donne
pas mais en tout cas j'aimerais vous
sortiez bien vous avez bien travaillé et
merci ça va participer
pour eux l'aventuré du carnaval est
terminée pour d'autres en revanche les
réjouissances ne font que commencer
alors que la fête bat son plein dans les
rues de venise
de jour comme de nuit c'est le grand
rendez-vous du carnaval pour gérard et
jean est invité au dîner de flavia donc
on va rentrer dans son palais voilà
c'est là on va inventer c'est les
chapeaux rouges comme on échappe au
rouge
c'est la première fois qu'il pousse la
porte d'un palais grâce à flavia ils
vont découvrir les codes de
l'aristocratie italienne
je me souviens et puis voilà laissez
vous aller
[Musique]
luxe calme et raffinement on est bien
loin des animations de rue pour
touristes dont gérard et ginette ont dû
se contenter des années précédentes
[Musique]
pour nous c'est la première année par
année commence à rentrer un petit peu
mieux
felicia pour vivre le carnaval comme
paul denigris le souhaite et c'est un
rêve éveillé passe en or l'année bompas
tu as tout le monde a des bobos
les met en valeur c'est magnifique c'est
grâce à l'argent de tous ses invités que
flavia et son mari lucas peuvent
entretenir et restaurer leur palais
alors la maîtresse de maison tient à
dévoiler sa dernière réalisation
cette fresque au plafond plutôt intime
[Musique]
c'est l'écrin dont il rêvait pour leurs
costumes qu'ils fabriquent depuis des
années et leur passion pour le carnaval
de venise va être récompensée au delà de
leurs espérances
avec un final en apothéose quelques
jours plus tard
gérard et ginette ont réussi à se faire
inviter à l'un des ballets les plus
odieux sur le thème du jardinage
comme à la cour de l'empereur ginette a
sorti pour l'occasion sa robe de 6,6
c'est avec des rêves de princes et de
princesses plein la tête qu'ils
repartiront en alsace dans quelques
jours
et déjà un nouvel objectif pour l'année
prochaine participer à la soirée la plus
prestigieuse le bal des doges
cet hymne à la démesure se tient chaque
année dans le palais pizza ni mort état
au bord du grand canal
on s'y presse en taxi bateau pour
découvrir les créations les plus
fantasques du carnaval
voilà c'est la partie garder
une poignée d'invités venus du monde
entier à payer 2500 euros pour pousser
les portes de ce monde féerique
sur trois étages des performances
assurée par 90 artistes internationaux
le thème cette année se créent des
paradis perdu impressionnant
c'est fantastique j'adore et avec la
musique c'est vraiment super le gratin
mondain et les grandes fortunes
internationales ont fait le déplacement
pour participer à ce bal masqué
totalement déjanté
c'est paraît-il l'un des plus glamours
et exclusif au monde
[Musique]
non
c'est le plus beau bal du monde
[Musique]
c'est une idée 10 choses à faire dans sa
vie avant de mourir
et vous l'avez déjà fait dix fois oui
j'ai déjà fait 10 fois c'est parfait à
chaque étage son ambiance et son univers
décalé comme ici où l'on croise
d'éduquer des comptes est sur une barre
de pole dance
mélange de mythes et de réalité c'est
cette ambiance féerique qui perpétue la
renommée du carnaval de venise inventé
il y a près de dix siècles